Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Merhabalar,
ben Doktor Yusuf Yeşil.
Size biraz çocukluğumdan bir hikâyeyle
başlamak istiyorum konuşmama.
Rize'nin yemyeşil tepeleri,
çay tarlalarının olduğu bir köyde büyüdüm,
çok sevimli bir köydü.
Ortasından, vadiden bir dere akıyordu.
Çok güzel bir çocukluk geçirdim.
Köy biraz şehre uzak olduğu için
babam haftada bir şehre inerdi,
servisle birlikte sabahleyin
ve akşam aynı servisle
birlikte geri dönerdi.
Ben de babamın getireceği o çikolataları,
bisküvileri merak ettiğim için
her akşam orada,
o köprüde babamı beklerdim.
Bir gün babam yine geldiğinde
onu beklerken bir baktığımda
gökyüzünde bir ışıltı
kaydığını fark ettim.
Bu ışıltıyı anlamlandıramamıştım
çünkü çocuktum daha,
henüz öyle bir bilgi yoktu
ve babam gelir gelmez sordum.
"Baba," dedim, "böyle bir ışıltı gördüm.
Bu ışıltı nedir?"
Onun bana bir kuyruklu
yıldız olduğunu söyledi.
Ben bunu duyduğumda
şaşırdım çünkü yıldızsınız,
ışıl ışıl parlıyorsunuz
ama bir kuyruğunuz var.
Sizin enerjinizi nereye
sarf etmeniz gerektiğini,
rotanızı belirleyen bir kuyruğunuz var
ve ondan sonra düşündüm,
aslında hayatımızda hepimiz
insanlar olarak birer kuyruklu yıldızız.
Hepimizin hayatlarında,
aile olsun, kültürümüz olsun,
yaşadıklarımız, hayatta
meslek seçiminde verdiğimiz kararlar,
tabularımız, alışkanlıklarımız,
hepsi aslında birer kuyruk.
Hatta onlarca, yüzlerce kuyruğumuz var.
Sonra döndüm, kendi hayatıma baktım.
Lise yıllarındaydım,
döndüm kendi hayatıma.
"Tıp fakültesini kazanacağım,
sonrasında doktor olacağım" gibi
böyle bende bir kuyruk vardı.
Hem ailem tarafından
hem arkadaşlarım tarafından
böyle bir kuyruk verilmişti bana
ve bunun için aslında yaşıyordum.
Bu kuyruk üzerine,
bunu gerçekleştirmek için yaşıyordum.
Sonrasında döndüm kendime, dedim ki:
Yani ben bunu istiyor muyum gerçekten?
Ben kendi hayatımı, kendi kuyruklarımı
kendim karar vermek istiyorum, dedim.
Kendi kuyruklarımı
kendim oluşturacağım, dedim.
Sonrasında birçok alana,
farklı alanlara ilgi duymaya başladım.
Masa tenisi oynadım, voleybol oynadım.
Bir ara elektronik müzik yaptım,
20'ye yakın beste çıkardım.
Resim, şiir yazmaya başladım.
En son çizgi filme çok fazla merak saldım.
Çizgi filmler yaptım, animasyonlar yaptım,
birçok yarışmaya katıldım,
ki yani bir fen lisesi öğrencisi için
bunlar hiç beklenmedik bir şeydi.
Hatta ben söylediğimde bunları
arkadaşlarıma veya etrafımdakilere,
çok değişik tepkiler alıyordum
ama seviyordum çünkü sıra dışıydım,
sıra dışı olmayı seviyordum.
O sıra dışında kalmayı seviyordum,
o düşünceyi seviyordum.
Aslında insanlar olarak baktığımızda
kariyer haritamızda özellikle hayatımızda,
upuzun planlar yapıyoruz.
Çok uzun süre sonrasına
çok detaylı planlar yapıyoruz,
adımlar koyuyoruz
ama aslında bazen sağımızda
solumuzda geçenleri kaçırabiliyoruz.
Belki de bir at gözlüğü gibi baktığımız
en uzun yolda detaylı planlar yaparken
çevremizdeki fırsatları kaçırabiliyoruz.
Özellikle bu çevredeki fırsatları
kaçırmada güven alanı dediğimiz,
yani "comfort zone" olarak geçen
konfor alanında kalmamızın
çok büyük etkisi var.
Nedir bu konfor alanı?
Örnek vereyim;
bir gün sabah evden çıktım,
iş yerine gittim,
iş yerinde iş arkadaşlarımla
birlikte çalışmaları yaptım,
akşam çıktım, en yakın arkadaşlarımla
birlikte en fazla gittiğim kafeye gittim,
sohbet ettik orada,
sonra eve döndüm.
Yani bunlar aslında
çok fazla tekrarladığım,
çok fazla deneyimlediğim
ve aslında beni en çok
güvende hissettiren deneyimler.
Yani ben bu deneyimlerde
kendimi güvende hissettiğim için
en fazla bunları yapıyorum.
Bu sayede beyin diyor ki
ben en az enerjiyle hayatımı
bu şekilde idame ettirebilirim.
Seni güven alanında tutarak
seni bu konfor alanında tutarak
en az enerjiyi harcayarak en az veriyle
karşılaşarak bunu devam ettirebilirim.
İşte bu bizim en fazla hataya
düştüğümüz yerlerden biri.
Eğer biz o konfor alanında
çok fazla kalırsak
yeni bilgiyle karşılaşamıyoruz.
Yeni bilgiyle karşılaşamadığımız için
yaratıcılığımız, hayal kurmamız,
farklı düşünmemiz, sıradanlıktan çıkıp
sıra dışı düşünmemiz zorlaşıyor.
Biz beynimize ne kadar çok yeni bilgi
gösterebilirsek o kadar sıra dışı,
o kadar fark yaratma
potansiyelimiz olabilir.
Bunu ben kendi bu özellikle
yaratıcılık ve sıra dışı düşünme,
özellikle günümüzde yapay zekâ
teknolojisinin gelişmesiyle
çok fazla önem kazandı.
Hepiniz biliyorsunuz,
işte çok fazla konuşuluyor;
yapay zekâ mesleklerimizi
elimizden alacak mı,
nereye gidiyor gibi.
Aslında bunun altında
çok basit bir soru var;
yani düşündüğünüzde eğer sizin mesleğiniz,
bir gün öncesinde, bir hafta
öncesinde, bir ay öncesinde yaptığınıza
çok benziyorsa yaptığınız iş hâlâ
o zaman yapay zekâ sizin
mesleğinizi elinizden alabilir.
Neden?
Çünkü bir algoritma
gibi bir iş yapıyorsanız
algoritma gibi bir kariyer planı,
bir algoritma gibi çalışıyorsanız
bir algoritmanın da
sizin işinizi elinizden alması
çok rahat beklenebilir bir şey.
O yüzden algoritmalardan çıkıp
bize bu dayatılan kuyruklardan çıkıp
farklı düşünme becerilerini
kazanmamız gerekiyor.
Yaratıcılık, sıra dışı düşünme,
duygusal zekâ gibi;
bu gibi özellikler günümüzde dijital çağda
en önemli özelliklerden biri olacak.
Kendi hayatımdan örnek vermek gerekirse
2015 yılındaydım, o zamanlar
hâlâ çizgi film yapıyordum
ve artırılmış gerçeklik, sanal gerçeklik
teknolojilerine aşina olmaya başlamıştım.
O zamanlar 3. ve 4. sınıfta Harvard
ve Stanford üniversitelerinde
birer yaz stajı gerçekleştirdim
tıp fakültesindeyken.
O stajlarımda yaptığım
çalışmalar beni çok etkilemişti
ve döndükten sonra Türkiye'ye,
bu teknolojileri bilimde kullanmak
için, sanatla birleştirebilmek için
bilim, sanat ve teknolojiyi
kendi girişimimi kurmaya karar verdim.
Bu fikri ilk arkadaşlarımla paylaştım,
dedim böyle böyle bir girişim fikrim var.
Tıp fakültesindeyim, altını çiziyorum
çünkü paylaştığım arkadaşlarım
da tıp fakültesi öğrencileri.
Bunu söyler söylemez,
"Aa Yusuf, ne yapıyorsun sen!
Önünde TUS denen bir sınav var,
Tıpta Uzmanlık Sınavı, ona çalışman lazım.
Ne alaka bir girişim!"
gibi çok farklı tepkiler aldım
ama bu tepkilerden çok fazla şaşırmadım.
Neden; çünkü ben
sıra dışı olmak istiyorsam
sıradan bir iş yapmak istemiyorsam
tepkiler de benden
sıra dışı olması lazımdı.
Yani kimse size "Hadi oo,
mükemmel, Devam et!" demez
çünkü sıradanlıktan kurtulup
sıra dışı bir iş yapıyorsanız
onun da tepkilerine hazır olup
cesareti kendinizde bulmanız gerekiyordu.
Ben de aynen böyle düşündüm.
Dedim, bu tepkiler beni işimden
alıkoyamaz, hayallerimden alıkoyamaz.
Ben bu işi yapacağım, dedim.
Sonrasında girişimimi kurdum.
Birlikte çalışmalar yapmaya
başladık küçük bir ekiple.
Sonrasında dünyada bilimsel
olarak sanal gerçeklikle izlenebilen
ilk animasyonu yaptık.
Bunu yaptıktan sonra çeşitli
dergilerde röportajlar verdik,
haberlere çıktık,
ekibimiz büyüdü, birçok
arkadaşla tanıştık derken
iş biraz büyüdü.
En son dünyanın en büyük
ilaç fuarlarından birinde,
PharmaAwards'da finalist olarak yer aldık.
Sonra tekrar başa döndüğümde baktım.
Yani ben o aşamadayken
o kararı veremeseydim
belki de şu an burada olmayacaktım.
Sonrasında çeşitli üniversitelerde,
özellikle tıp fakültelerinde
dijital teknolojiler,
tıpta nasıl bizi değiştirecek,
tıptaki pratiklerimize nasıl yenilikler
katacak başlıklı konuşmalar yaptım.
Bu konuşmalarda bu teknolojileri anlattım,
girişimcilik serüvenimi anlattım
ve bu konuşmalar sonrasında,
genellikle bana her zaman bir 5-6 arkadaş,
tıp fakültesi öğrencisi arkadaş gelirdi.
Derdi ki, "Yusuf abi, bizim de senin gibi
böyle böyle projelerimiz var.
Böyle böyle fikirlerimiz var
ama cesaret edemiyoruz, yapamıyoruz.
Yani o ilhamı, o cesareti
alamıyoruz," diyorlardı.
Yani ben onu duyunca aslında direkt aklıma
kendi girişimimi kurduğum zamanlar geldi;
oradaki cesareti bulamayışım,
oradaki benim korkularım
ve yüzleştiklerim aklıma geldi.
Sonrasında 2016'nın sonralarına doğru
girişimimizin birinci
senesinin sonlarıydı,
bir gün arkadaşlarla birlikte
oturuyorduk kantinde.
Sohbet ediyorduk, girişimimi anlatıyordum:
Şöyle şöyle yapıyoruz,
bu ürünleri çıkardık,
bu teknolojileri kullanıyoruz.
Sonrasında bir baktım,
televizyon ekranında spiker
bir haberi anons geçiyordu.
Haber aynen şu şekildeydi:
Evrendeki ilk kuyruksuz
kuyruklu yıldız bulundu.
Hatta ismini Manx adı verilen dünyadaki
tek kuyruksuz kedi türünden alıyordu.
Yani bunu duyunca çok şaşırdım
çünkü biliyordum, evrende yalnız değildim.
Benim gibi kuyruğundan kopup
kendi yol haritasını kendi belirleyecek
başka biri daha vardı,
başka bir şey daha vardı.
O benim için vücut bulmuş bir hâldi.
Benim felsefemin, hayatım boyunca
yaptıklarımın vücut bulmuş bir hâliydi.
Bunu düşündükten sonra
tekrar o öğrenciler aklıma geldi.
Dedim ki, "Benim için bu haber nasılsa,
benim için bu haber nasıl
bir vücut bulmuş ilham kaynağıysa
ben de onlar için oydum."
Yani ben de onlar için
önündeki ilham veren bir örnektim.
O yüzden bundan sonraki çalışmalarımda da
hep artık bu felsefeyle,
bu bilinçte ve bu sorumlulukla
yaptığımız şeyleri devam ettirdim.
Ben de sizlere hayatınızda
kuyruklarınızdan kopup
kendi kuyruklarınızı, kendi yol
haritanızı kendiniz belirleyeceğiniz
ve başkalarına ilham olabileceğiniz
bir hayat diliyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)